in Taiwan the subways don't require
pants and a boy in love wait
it's episode 25 of I mg there is nothing
better than sniffing hippo but except a
jar full of kiddy put things in front of
your face to get a kiss or a fish face
or just dress up in Spidey costumes you
can do it outside in bars in hotel rooms
but if you want to see a real spider
female here you go
BuzzFeed collected cats with mustaches
some are classy
some are hipster some are head to ler
and some are man-made but what really
matters is women with mustaches enjoy
[Music]
this guy owns a lot of women's shoes and
he poses in them a lot but he's
following in excellent footsteps
here's grito and zoom out a little bit
too cute here's a perspective illusion
that will trick your I of fingernail I
shot this at the Griffith Observatory in
LA it's a random assortment of stars
that looks like gobbledygook except from
one angle the angle that Earth has at
that point they all align to form the
Big Dipper
this fish makes cats freak out and on
its side this microwave is very happy
and gift break that's cool but check out
this stop a few months ago the Mexican
army confiscated 134 tons of marijuana
which they burned but as long as we can
still play basketball on a nipple ring
hoop the world is fine the guy behind
anatomical Yoshi has now made a rubix
brain cube the only thing more puzzling
is Justin Bieber's underwear ad but a
cat's paws can be teddy bears mr. and
mrs. Smith calm helps you book luxury
and boutique hotels but can you tell me
which television show is hidden in this
picture ah decom showcased cool
sandwiches the famous pizza sandwich a
grande panini a Rubik's Cube inspired
treat and a ham sandwich sorry a hand
sandwich if you prefer to meats
Adie also brought us the best hotdog
tattoos guilty of being delicious wait
really I want to date her and this one
is just a zombie I'm kidding there's a
hot dog if you're going to roast hot
dogs or marshmallows while camping use
these as suggested by Mahmud on
facebook.com slash vsauce gaming over
there frederick showed us a fun trick
hey AppStore you got a light sorry
no matches Steven showed us the saddest
chocolate chip cookie ever and Edward
gave us a cute couple sharing a sweater
while cooking human skulls kids can
cause messes especially when you give
them a marker or a marker and a little
brother I leave you with Star Wars cats
be sure to subscribe to Vsauce and now
that this episode is over
go watch loot on vsauce2 it's just like
IMG except it's stuff I found this week
that you can actually own click here to
watch loot and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]